president barack obama told reporters he
was hopeful of future developments after
a landmark one-on-one conversation with
his iranian counterpart
just now i spoke on the phone with
president rouhani of the islamic
republic of iran
the two of us discussed our ongoing
efforts to reach an agreement over
iran's nuclear program
i reiterated to president rouhani what i
said in new york
while there will surely be
important obstacles to moving forward
and success is by no means guaranteed
i believe we can reach
a comprehensive solution
in new york rouhani acknowledged the
historic importance of talks aimed at
settling the nuclear impasse between the
u.n and iran and credited voters at home
the environment that's been created as a
result of this early phase of the
discussion is quite different from the
past he said the people of iran have
helped this new environment to come
about
their voices during the elections in
june lead to a new environment in iran
and in the world
rouhani again underscored that he wanted
to resolve the dispute as quickly as
possible and he promised a plan for
talks next month in geneva
you